what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's monday october 12th
the joint podcast is brought to you by
we're introducing to the show
lucy nicotine gum listen to me
smoking sucks dick you gotta step
outside your clothes smell like [ __ ]
people trick treat you like you got the
heave it's a [ __ ] nightmare
now when you're craving the smoke you
just need a little something to satisfy
the habit
you step outside you take a moment you
pop this in your mouth
and you're as good as [ __ ] brand new
to top my goo
listen it's 20 20. things are rough
enough
you don't need to smoke anymore get lucy
today so you're prepared
so when you get the itch you're ready to
go lucy
actually tastes good i even switched
over from the [ __ ] i was [ __ ] taking
comes in three flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and palmer [ __ ] granite are
you crazy or what
and they've also got a cherry ice
flavored losses
that will make your [ __ ] wig spin
like maurice
do me a favor uncle joey's joint
listeners go to lucy dot co
ceo lucy dot co ceo
and use promo coach joey to get 20
percent off the products
including the gum or the lozenges that's
lucy dot go use promo code
joey at checkout also i have this
disclaimer
warning warning warning
this product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco nicotine
is an addictive sub chemical just go to
lucy
dot co and be sure you use promo code
joey the church also wants to welcome
one of my [ __ ] favorites all right
from the heart of new jersey draftkings
listen
week five of football is in the books
now it's time
to review the tape and get ready for
week six
listen there's a ton of [ __ ] games
i'm watching if i
watch the four o'clock miami game i
watch the late game
you got monday night tonight draftkings
is back
with this can't miss offer if you
haven't tried it yet
this is time to jump on it because
they're giving all new users the chance
to receive
a sign up bonus of up to one thousand
dollars
you put in the grand they give you a
grand who else is giving you dick these
days
you're still waiting for your [ __ ]
unemployment check [ __ ] [ __ ]
and to top that off they got great odds
boost
every sunday so make money with your
feet up
plus you got the baseball [ __ ]
playoffs coming
so what the [ __ ] are we talking about
here we got action do me a favor
right now download the top-rated
draftking sportsbook app
now and use coach church to get a
thousand dollars
you didn't hear me did you you get a
grand when you
get the draftking sportsbook app and use
code church
only at draftkings sportsbook and here's
the part the lawyers make you say
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana
or pennsylvania only deposit requires 25
percent
times of play through and restrictions
do apply
see draftkings.com for sportsbook for
details
you got a gaming problem there's help
you call 1-800 gambler
and if you're indiana you call 1-800
with it
and tell them uncle joey sent you but
first download the draftking sports book
app
and use code church cop suckers the
church is also brought to you by my
personal favorite
cbd lion whether it's the roland
whether it's the gummies whether it's
the cream
whether it's the bath wall whether it's
detentious
cbd lion has you covered go to
cbdlion.com right now
and press in joey and get 20
10 i don't know what percent you'll get
something to [ __ ] off
delivered right to your [ __ ] house no
more [ __ ] buying this [ __ ]
from some orange guy at some [ __ ]
liquor store
or footstore or nothing uncle joey's got
you
cbdlion.com go to cbd lion
for the third party live results and
press in joey
and that's it and that's that
candles lit [ __ ]
the joint is about to begin
look who it is [ __ ]
czech 1-2 welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
for uncle joey's joining us monday the
12th of october i hope you had a great
weekend
your family you're safe the whole
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh thank you for all the condolences
from my friend roger holloway
the wake is tonight from four to eight
up in uh north bergen the problem is
there's no school today and i already
made plans with the girls and another
family and their kids
to [ __ ] go down to the beach and uh
spend the afternoon so hopefully we'll
get back in time i can jump in my car
and go up there you know uh roger was a
dear friend
part of the reason i'm still [ __ ]
here and uh where i got my comedy chops
was from [ __ ] roger so i owe him a
lot of christmases at his house
a lot of uh holidays thanksgivings
you know he was just one of the families
where i grew up in one of the houses
where i grew up in i mean his parents
are gone
but uh i still gotta do what i gotta do
you know what i'm saying it's it's that
easy
you know that is going around a lot
today a lot of uh
people contact me joey my uncle died my
aunt died i mean
the guy who bought the house from lost
his father august 1st
and his mother september 17th
and uh you know this just goes back to
to talk about
what happened with like roger you know
he was fine he was sober
everything was great 20 years
part of a church went down to katrina
helped people
get it together and then one of his
parents passed and the second one of his
parents passed
and let me tell you something man
there's nothing like pain
and unless you've had pain you know all
these [ __ ] experts
oh alcoholism is a disease drug abuse is
a disease yeah it's all great and dandy
if that's how you feel about it
but i think it all stems to pain i mean
when it came to me doing drugs
it came to [ __ ] pain i was walking
around i [ __ ] you know remember when
they had those pain specialists in
florida
and people moving to florida oh my back
hurts my swords
that wasn't the pain they were there for
they were there for some internal pain
that you don't even know about
you don't know about it way afterward
when you
quit doing drugs and that pain comes up
you address it and you move the [ __ ] on
and then you wonder to yourself oh it's
a miracle i don't do drugs normal you
know the miracle is
you figured out where the [ __ ] pain
was and you solved it
when you take it you take an aspirin
you're like how do i know where this
aspen's going
if i take an aspect how does it know
that my [ __ ] foot hurts
well it's the same thing with pain
listen man i had a lot of [ __ ] pain
going into comedy
that to my mother father [ __ ] divorce
losing a child you know i had tons of
pain
and i made it work for me yes i also
spent a half a billion dollars on
cocaine
trying to numb me the [ __ ] down but it
wasn't a miracle
that i [ __ ] uh got clean in 2007. it
wasn't
a it was a miracle what it was was
i realized what the pain was dealt
with it and moved on long was the pain
of my mother and father that's [ __ ]
i mean you still feel it from time to
time holidays
certain things but was i walking around
like my mommy died unless you wear it
like a [ __ ] badge on your [ __ ]
sleeve
then people are gonna know the last
big chunk of pain that that [ __ ] made
me go through comedy
was my war with my ex and i don't know
what happened
i mean me not seeing her you know made
my
addiction [ __ ] go on fire i'm going
back 2004
2005. my addiction was so out of control
that it's just why even go into the
stories you've heard them all
but they were out of [ __ ] control me
sitting here looking back
at 13 years ago somewhere along the line
i must have wrote in a journal that i
was over my daughter or something like
that
and i gotta tell you something the pain
disappeared
and once the pain disappears you won't
need [ __ ] drugs no more
at least i don't listen i got i got a
couple pains now
i smoke if you smoke weed i don't even
consider that a [ __ ] drug
for you people who make a big deal about
smoking weed
give yourself a [ __ ] break okay
legalizing weed i've been watching
marijuana
people smoking marijuana since i was
close to five
and i gotta tell you something even as
an outsider looking in
i used to go to movies with my godfather
and he would smoke a joint right in
front of me
and he would giggle and then afterward
we would go to tad steakhouse and get a
[ __ ] steak or something in lower
manhattan
so what crime had he committed what else
did he do on the weed he did nothing
it just makes you [ __ ] chill out
speaking of weed i don't want you to
think i'm [ __ ] being a half a
fruitcake let me tell you something
after wednesday's podcast i was spraying
that spray right
i had that spray in that desk i brought
that from california with me
i bought the regular spray the thousand
milligram spray
and i brought to sleep on because all
the products in california especially
edibles
are making a sleep product even abx my
man just on
abx they're making a capsule that's 50
milligrams 100 milligrams
but they also make a 10 milligram that's
just for sleep
they put melatonin in there and
chamomile and every other [ __ ] thing
you know last week i put up a video for
on it on it's got some great [ __ ] uh
whatever the [ __ ] melatonin turkey juice
in the [ __ ] thing you
just do six sprays of honey [ __ ]
turkey juice whatever the [ __ ] you're
going down trust me
last week i had a one night where i did
three things under my tongue of the
kokomo tincture
okay i ate two of the kokomo 2 milligram
thc
pills i got a cup of tea
i went into the living room i don't know
what i was watching
and 10 minutes later i woke up with the
teeth built all over me i had tea on my
socks tea on my sweats
i had tea [ __ ] everywhere that's how
strong
this kokomo [ __ ] is mixed with the
melatonin i need
all the help i can get at night and like
i said i can't do the sleeping pills at
night because i'll [ __ ] die in my
sleep
and i don't need i don't want to die
right now but last
[ __ ] wednesday i'm [ __ ] around
with you guys you know
doing all these
what the [ __ ] did people think of yeah i
get all these emails joey
you're a new jet like they're haters
joey you're in jersey what are you going
to smoke now
that's what i'm smoking now cut suckers
a vapor
nobody even knows nothing i can put it
in the car with me nobody knows nothing
you can blow this in the cops face
they're like what's the matter i got
asthma [ __ ] now
this is what they gave chris christopher
at the [ __ ] hospital but he went in
there that fat
[ __ ] anyway here's to you [ __ ]
abx
edibles on a beautiful monday morning
[ __ ]
you like joey why would you ruin your
day [ __ ] you
i'm getting my day started right jack
some people take vitamins
i open up with a [ __ ] edible of life
and death just to get the party started
so
i do that [ __ ] spray i'm [ __ ]
around with you guys
what could have been 10 in the [ __ ]
morning
i don't know about three o'clock
i'm at the park with my daughter my wife
looks over me she goes
what the [ __ ] have you been smoking i go
nothing i haven't smoked since my little
breakfast [ __ ] joint
and she goes you got to see the look on
your face right now you are [ __ ]
hired as [ __ ]
and all sudden i i sat at the park i'm
making believe like i'm looking at trees
and blue birds and [ __ ]
and i was just looking out into the
[ __ ] abyss i'm like i am
[ __ ] up so we had to come home
uh and get chant you know went right to
the park it was one of those days
listen when you're a parent you're just
running all day especially in new jersey
you're [ __ ] running all [ __ ] day
so i uh
we came home i took like a piss washed
my hands
mercy put out a little kickboxing suit
and we went over
the kickboxing when i went upstairs
to watch wash my hands i looked at
myself in the mirror
i looked like [ __ ] a body was
floating i mean my eyes were popping out
of my head like marty fellman did
[ __ ] an ounce of blow
both of them were popping out of my
[ __ ] head i had to put vizina and i
had to put cream
under my eyes just so i was presentable
enough
to go to her kickboxing class i don't
want those people talking bad about me
especially when my daughter's there you
know
but when i came back i was like i was
[ __ ] up and i didn't make it to
vinnie's
and it went [ __ ] great man so ha
you [ __ ] thought i was gonna
get all [ __ ] up
and not make it to vinnie's like right
now i'm just eating that over because i
know what my day is like
i gotta go away with the girls i'm gonna
probably end up walking [ __ ] three
miles
my hamstring is gonna hurt i'm not gonna
give a [ __ ] cause i'm gonna be too
[ __ ] up to even think about my
hamstring
and then i'll probably have my friend
pick me up and we'll shoot up to the
[ __ ] weight together
i'll see some friends i'll give some
hugs i'll be in a
covale situation but we make our best
when you're in a cuvvodio situation
you get home and you burn your clothes
you understand me it's like you killed
your girlfriend and buried her in the
woods
same thing you [ __ ] burn your clothes
sneak his socks
you don't want of that for mild to hide
covered mix
on your [ __ ] clothes you have a
saying or in your lungs
that formaldehyde's a [ __ ]
compared with the [ __ ] covert you'll
never
all those people who went to waste half
of them [ __ ] died you imagine dying
because you went to see somebody dead
how dumb do you feel mccasket i should
have mined my business and stayed home
and watched the six o'clock news what
the [ __ ]
but he was my brother he was there for
me from the ages i mean i knew roger
from probably mckinley
but we reconnected in high school and it
was
uh you know
i i think in my life and i wonder how
the [ __ ]
i didn't go the easy way out like i just
didn't go the easy way out i had every
opportunity to go the easy way out and
because anybody who's lost a mother
knows overwhelming pain
especially when you're a [ __ ] child
you know
let's face it yeah i tell you guys i was
a man at 16.
i was a [ __ ] [ __ ] child that was
just learning i had to become a man
overnight
and i don't know how i [ __ ] did not
jump off a bridge
but i'll tell you why because i had
friends like stinky
i had friends like roger i had friends
like fernie
and friends like [ __ ] mike ronnie i
had friends
and friends that kept me entertained
and this is why i tell you even with
this covert right now in this isolation
it's not going to work for you you got
to be around some people
i'm not talk i don't want you to go down
to a [ __ ] protest and jump upside
down and [ __ ]
you know state some stupid [ __ ] that oh
debunk the belief
yeah that's great that's gonna work i
want you to just go
you got a friend you got a cousin start
by going and talking to them one-on-one
on a one-on-one
basis buy them a cup of coffee how cheap
are you
buy them a cup of [ __ ] coffee talk to
them start this rap game how do i know
because i know how to get out of a hole
i have been in thousands of [ __ ]
holes you want to get out of a hole you
got to do it the right way
you got to write you got to talk to
people i mean
six weeks ago look at that [ __ ] tape
i made
from corporate housing when i'm smoking
outside look at the bags under my eyes
look at my hands shaking
all that was taken care of when i go to
a psychiatrist all of a sudden i got
i went to a voodoo doctor no i went back
to basics
alpha brain notebook rapping with people
not on the phone not texting
showing up to the house with a [ __ ]
mask on
let's go in the backyard get a little
vitamin [ __ ] d
and let's talk and once i went from one
to three
to four to the florentine little
gathering which i
i almost passed out from the [ __ ]
anxiety almost passed out from the
[ __ ] anxiety
and little by little i've been able just
to conquer
little things and i did the movie set
which was [ __ ] scary
you know i got the same fears you
[ __ ] have i don't want you to
think that i walk around with a body
armor shield on
i don't give a [ __ ] you got to be
cautious now there's supposed to be a
second wave coming
i don't want you guys to get caught in
that second wave so you avoid colonial
situations whatever the [ __ ] cavalia
situations
that's it and that's that but there's
things that you have to do and just go
well [ __ ] prepared i mean i'm
plugging my ears
i'm plugging my nose i'm doing
everything i'm going in there minimum
i'm gonna go in
walk straight to the casket kneel down
say my prayers
put something in the [ __ ] casket i
don't know what you know i got to figure
out what he liked
maybe chocolate bar who the [ __ ] knows
go shake the family's hand i'm going
right back outside and breathe
anybody who wants to talk we could do it
the [ __ ] outside let's get some fresh
air i'm not sitting in this [ __ ]
den of covert waiting for [ __ ] hunan
breath to hit me in the [ __ ] neck
because somebody's got to be there all
[ __ ] up on this [ __ ] so
but that's it and that's that that's
part of my [ __ ] uh journey to go over
there tonight and
pay my respects to a man who basically
saved my [ __ ] life
i can't tell you how many [ __ ]
dinners i had in his life i can't tell
you
how many nights he made me [ __ ] laugh
when the last thing
i wanted to do is [ __ ] laugh but
that's the way it goes you gotta do what
you gotta do
it's time for a little nicotine gum
i'm gonna show you this lucy how it
works very nice pomegranate
he's just [ __ ] popping
and nobody gets that [ __ ] feeling sir
[ __ ] delicious [ __ ] delicious
no sugar so you're fine
you won't get no [ __ ] cavities the
worst thing you could do who the [ __ ]
knows
nothing so enjoy your lucy
cole pomegranate gum you're gonna
[ __ ] be happy i referred you
so in the middle of all this last
wednesday being high
i came to a conclusion or something i
went i went to mercy's kickboxing class
we either alternate you know why both of
us go there i mean there's only a couple
chairs for parents and
you know if i'm going to go 4 30 maybe
at least my wife could just stay home
get the house ready
she'll cook so sometimes this time we
both went together
we're like [ __ ] let's both go down
there you know
i'm [ __ ] higher than [ __ ] i'm trying
to keep it together thank god for visine
cold water to the face and other [ __ ]
procedures i use little neck ice to the
neck
i [ __ ] went down there and they had a
nice little kid class going they had
about six kids
you got to sit inside and watch them the
windows were open
but it gave me a chance to look at my
daughter from the outside
[ __ ] she has gotten big
you know like i'm looking at it going
and then when it came time to strike the
punches and to kick
i was like holy [ __ ] she's [ __ ] not
bad at this
now do i want to be a fighter no do i
want to beat people up no
i just wanted to know how to protect
herself so she's not scared i mean last
week
i had a running with [ __ ] boys i
don't give a [ __ ]
she'll probably be over there today no
tomorrow tuesdays
we go over there and they [ __ ] skate
and they [ __ ] jump up and down and
they do listen all those [ __ ]
kids do everything in one afternoon
they're like us
this is jersey this ain't california
where the kids stay in on the computers
watching their father's bad tv shows
this is
this these kids are out they play with
football
they play baseball they're on scooters
with helmets
then they throw the scooters away then
they get on [ __ ] bicycles
then they're [ __ ] then we order a
pizza through then it starts to get dark
and they bring out all these [ __ ]
trucks and [ __ ] jimmy florentine's got a
hill these [ __ ] get in there
and they swing and then they push
themselves back up they do this
constantly
and i'm sitting there going my mother
will kill me if she knows i got a right
side on the street
doing this with cars [ __ ] it
this is why i moved here so she could
[ __ ] be a [ __ ]
you know a hammer of god i didn't want
to be one of those [ __ ]
[ __ ] girls from l.a oh my god i gotta
tell you about my instagram friends [ __ ]
you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you that nanny that
raised you
and the [ __ ] woman who spit you out
of a [ __ ] that didn't really want to
have you
because she put a [ __ ] mexican nanny
on you what good is that [ __ ]
i got nothing against mexican people
they're great nannies but
why have a kid if you're gonna have a
nanny unless you're [ __ ] donald trump
or somebody [ __ ] important why the
[ __ ] do you have three or four [ __ ]
nannies
get your life together raise your kid
you dumb [ __ ]
that was a problem that way all those
kids were raised by nannies
then they come around my kid and they're
acting like [ __ ] savages
and my kid would look at him and go what
the [ __ ] is going on with these people
there's no connection sure there's no
connection
the kids got a conduit between them and
their [ __ ] parents
who the [ __ ] has a conduit between them
and their parents
don't get me started anyway after
brighter [ __ ] things
i'm looking at her
i have a little anxiety that [ __ ]
spray didn't help
the reef it didn't help whatever i'm
going through didn't help
me getting on stage i uncle vinnie's
that night didn't help i had all these
things going through my mind
but the [ __ ] thing that stuck out the
most through my mind was watching mercy
and thinking to myself the second chance
that i've gotten in life
i don't really understand if you guys
know the second chance i got thrown at
me in this beautiful life
i lost a daughter i was in prison
i had no [ __ ] prospects i got on
stage lost
just like the way you guys are at 21 22
23
24 25 you're lost
you might want to do music you think you
want to be in the travel resort
you have a friend whose uncle works at
[ __ ] the stock exchange
who said he'd get your job making six
figures you're all over the place
what you need to find is your passion
what you [ __ ] love
and then run from there listen when you
find what you love you'll do it for free
if you like sucking dick
if you like sucking a dick right like if
you wake up in the morning and go hmm
i wish there was a dick i could [ __ ]
yank on right now
[ __ ] it suck 10 dicks a day for 500
above
that's 5 000 you're making money even if
you take a day off and go down to one
dick
it's not [ __ ] bad you know what i'm
saying you can take care of that cavity
what i'm saying is you got to find your
passion and your passion will make it do
it for free
whatever you're passionate you don't
give a [ __ ] about do you like digging
go dig and then eventually you go to a
funeral parlor a funeral grave place
and go i like digging and they're like
well we use big machinery i don't give a
[ __ ]
i want to dig six feet holes every day
go dig
i'll pay eight dollars an hour go dig
and you dig and you made
you created something yourself
do you know what i'm saying are you are
you [ __ ] with me or am i talking to
myself here i think i'm talking to
myself
i think that [ __ ] edible's hitting it
already i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on or where we [ __ ] were but
fine with your passion i'm looking at
this little girl and i'm like how
[ __ ] lucky am i
that i got this second chance of life
and i attacked it like a soldier
i did everything by the [ __ ] book you
know how proud i
am do you have any [ __ ] idea i was
never
ever i've never been proud of myself at
all longer shot all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just another day at the [ __ ]
park but to me
to have a household that there's love in
the house
that i have a little girl that's happy
that's got a smile on her face
no more living in l.a no more she would
come home
and she picked up on it how does a
[ __ ] seven-year-old girl
pick up on it she didn't call them
gentiles or [ __ ] white people she
called them
fancy people i don't like those fancy
people daddy they act too fancy
so she read it not because
listen my best little friend is an
african-american girl and they go meet
each other
every [ __ ] weekend that's where they
are now they went to a pumpkin patch
today to pick apples and whatever the
[ __ ]
my daughter's cooler than [ __ ] i raised
like that but
again my point was that i got a second
chance
and i [ __ ] jumped all over it and you
know what
it proved one thing to me that there is
a [ __ ] god in this guy there is
something buddha
something everything happens for a
reason man you know my friend mike my
brother mike
his wife died he can't figure it out
nobody can figure it out you know what
happens
years from now you get the answer
everything that happens has a
repercussion
it is going to affect you somewhere else
later on
and it's going to lessen that pain
you're going to get a lesson from it
do you are you with me like for years i
was angry at my mom i went off kilter
my natural compass was off my inside was
off
my belief system had been down
i kept pushing pushing pushing i found
comedy
i found comedy got at least that that
you know what i'm saying
that put a little bit of a smile on my
face i didn't like being 25
and thinking i had to go into a job
every day five days a week
eight to five and when i'm 65 they give
you a goddamn watch and they send you on
your way
and you have the right to tell somebody
oh i worked with gillette for 35 years
who gives a [ __ ]
you went and did something to somebody
else for 35 years what did you do for
yourself
that was the main [ __ ] question did
you do anything for yourself did you
draw a picture
did you take a vacation did you start
your own little business
this coveted opportunity right now is
gonna give you guys a lot of
there's no work you know happy you've
lost your job
half of yours got furloughed now what
are you gonna do
take the little savings you got left you
know you put a little money away
and get the simplest things and start
your [ __ ] life
whatever you want to do whether it's
pictures photography jumping off clips
and taking pictures
now is the time listen to me we got shut
down with a lot of places
to do the podcast a lot of avenues no
max no whatever
we're running here i'm basic [ __ ]
we'll run in here on a [ __ ] iphone
why
because my passion is to get the word
out to you people
i don't give a [ __ ] how we get it to you
people if you want i can go
get a fancy [ __ ] studio and
water with lemons in it to impress you
and you know the whole thing
i'm not here to impress you that's
that's that ship sunk
[ __ ] 20 years ago i'm not here for
the [ __ ] johnnies
i'm here to share love with you on
mondays and wednesdays
i'm here to talk to you i'm here to make
you laugh make you cry
just have a [ __ ] good time that's
what uncle joey does
whether you're in or not i don't give a
frenchman's [ __ ]
this is what i'm trying to do here
anyway i don't know if any of you guys
saw the comedy store documentary or
you're watching it or you're into
watching it
i suggest you watch all five of them
learn they tell you some of the history
i mean last week it was basically the
beginning of the store
and the freddie prince incident that a
lot of you people did not know
i mean happy years don't even know
freddie prince is
you know freddie prince junior and even
he [ __ ] kind of disappeared
he's still around i think he does a
podcast with josh
but it covered the end of uh freddie
prince's career
last night i had a ton of [ __ ] going on
so i haven't i taped it
but i haven't watched it but i'll tell
you what if you're not watching it watch
it
because you're going to learn a couple
things about that [ __ ] place that
place
and yeah you guys have been hearing it
for [ __ ] 30 years from either rogan
or my podcast
or other podcast but now you get to see
you get a little look into the comedy
store what happened there
the events that happened there the first
wave
of hicks and kenyson and dice
and [ __ ] lenny clark
then the pawnee paul mooney years
and then it comes up to our years
hopefully they used me if they did good
if they didn't let me tell you something
i was there from 97.
i got nothing to prove to nobody you
want to see
me footage at the store or you didn't
see the footage at the store
who gives a [ __ ] come see me live that's
where you'll see the [ __ ] comedy
store capisce [ __ ]
capisce that's what i'm talking about
here we're all [ __ ] good
because i had a great time at vinnie's i
really [ __ ] did
i it was uh if you see i've gotten
every time you see me it's not that i'm
looking thinner it's not that i
i'm going to [ __ ] whatever school
it's that
the relief the tension and the stress
has been pulled off me
you know just getting on stage just
getting that monotony going that rhythm
going
that is exactly what i [ __ ] needed
you know between
doing the podcast for you guys last week
and getting on stage i want to thank you
i really want to thank you
you guys thank you you guys are sitting
over there thinking [ __ ]
no you guys are helping me
you guys are my dr melfi you understand
me
i come here once a week with no attitude
and i talk to you straight from the
[ __ ] heart straight from the gut
letting you know what the [ __ ] is going
on because what do you want from me
i got nothing to [ __ ] tell you i'm
just trying to tell you the facts
as they come in and whatever i talk to
lee
he's doing okay he's uh starting a
patreon
he's getting this podcast where he's
going to revisit all the church episodes
the drugs he did little things that you
don't know happened before the podcast
maybe a camera blew up maybe something
happened
just to explain each podcast he's going
to go through 800 [ __ ]
podcasts i want to wish him luck and
he's going to do a patreon
where he's going to do jumping jacks on
[ __ ] and zoom so that's going to be
great listen
i know you like porn give it a breather
lee doing jumping jacks on zoom is gonna
blow your [ __ ] mind okay
that's where the real [ __ ] laughter
comes that dude is a [ __ ] trip
so for you people who ask me all the
time have you spoken to lee
yes i speak to lee twice a day i love
him dearly
i'm encouraging him i'm scared for him
that [ __ ] drive with the blizzard
behind them
but that's the way it [ __ ] goes but
man
i want to thank you guys especially the
patreon people
you know the messages you know just
just me interacting with you even on
facebook
you know facebook those three weeks that
i didn't have a computer
i mean i'm just buried in messages
so if you've sent me a message on
facebook and i haven't gotten back to
you it's because i didn't have facebook
for three [ __ ] weeks
i don't have it on my ipad the only
thing i have on my ipad
is twitter and [ __ ] patreon
just to keep the light because i was
going on the road i don't want facebook
and all that and then next you know i'm
on the road and i'm on social media
i'd rather use the road just to write
come up with new ideas
fresh concepts whatever you know right
outline my book
i was telling my friend before i started
here that's something that i've been
outlining again i've started i i found
what the color point was this story
is just going to be from july 16 1991
the present see we were trying to put
too much stuff
my childhood all those stories you've
heard over the years
and stand up closely
and stand up comment excuse me they put
this gum to the side
and stand up comedy whatever the [ __ ]
we're talking about all into one
but now this changes this [ __ ]
changes the [ __ ] game
so my stand-up uh you know i'm gonna put
like
on the computer i got little different
pages i got
stand-up comedy today i got all this
stuff
and what i did was i took the book and
it starts off with me getting on stage
and the difficulties i had with getting
on stage
and then we work forward the divorce
the pain what fueled me you know
what really had me a lot of people you
don't know is that
i had this personal war going on my
stepfather from
the time my mother got [ __ ] and put in
the hole
to 1985. i had this personal war
that had this money coming to me and
between you and i guys
i did have the money coming to me okay
not the amount
i thought i had but i did have some
money coming to me
let's say a hundred and fifty thousand i
mean
my mother had some property in florida
that she had sold
uh she had the house she had the bar
there was a little money there
i got dick from it and i was angry and i
was frustrated
and i was confused and i was hurt you
know so i i
staged this personal war with my
stepfather i
went to colorado to learn how to be a
hitman
and how to shoot people silently and all
this [ __ ]
i was a [ __ ] mess i was just a young
mess so for you
guys on patreon that are following and
you
send me messages telling me that you're
going through this and that
in 1983
i was training to be a [ __ ] hitman
you know what 1983 puts me at 20 years
old
you want to talk about [ __ ] confusion
i wanted to be a [ __ ] hit man how
broken are you
at 20 that you want to [ __ ] kill
people for a living on contract
and i was training for it i was learning
how to use every weapon i had a friend
that
just [ __ ] you know was a [ __ ]
vietnam vet that a specialty was killing
and this is what i wanted to do so i my
plan was to go back to new york in 84
and [ __ ] shoot him but you know what
i didn't have the balls i knew i
i knew that he was a lot slicker than i
was
you know i'm 57 years old i see the move
before it even unfolds
if i make a turn onto my block like when
i lived in l.a what do you think i left
l.a for because
i didn't want to be there no more no
because i saw the move coming
it doesn't take a [ __ ] genius and now
i get calls from
l.a every two days from people telling
me that there was a carjacking
yesterday i got a call you remember i
told you [ __ ]
when you pulled out of the podcast
street
and went on to chandler there was a
bridge over chandler
and there was homeless people there and
every night they would start
a little [ __ ] fire like it was the
cub scouts like they're just sitting
around like
you know roasting [ __ ] their fingers
because they got no marshmallows what
the [ __ ] are you roasting
you putting like your finger in there
with sugar and sucking on it you're
homeless your mother will go for broke
who who knows what the [ __ ] these people
were doing
but then i told lee when i go leave when
you go home tonight
check out the [ __ ] the underpass
see how many people live under the
underpass and make sure
they got a fire that [ __ ] called
me that night he was joey they got a
fire going again
well guess what happened they did flies
flies flies now
it's [ __ ] 80 degrees that night it's
90 [ __ ] degrees here in california
why the [ __ ] do you have a fire
so i guess that all these homeless
villages developed on the under these
bridges
and i guess about two weeks ago somebody
lit them all on fire
with the homeless people in there
homeless people are [ __ ] scattering
that is the mind of los angeles right
now
this is what i'm telling you [ __ ]
people i didn't leave there because
i left there because it was turning
into a different direction hey a lot of
you guys living in new york or just
moved on new york
go to new york at night look what
happens look what bill burke said in
this [ __ ] thing the other day didn't
moran has got punched in the head on the
upper west side it couldn't be no better
than that but that
is what's going on that's what's going
on in all the major [ __ ] cities this
tough top top creepy [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i'm telling you listen i don't give a
[ __ ] get everything ready
get the bb gun ready the gun ready the
bow and arrow
the bazooka start working the spitball
machine again
when was the last time you shot a
spitball i shot his football last week
just to practice
just to get him in [ __ ] you know
people's eyeballs because remember when
you were a kid you were great with the
spitball
six feet away you could shoot a
[ __ ] like nothing i don't care
what you got to do
you got to protect yourself and protect
your family when i talk to these people
in l.a
they're waiting for a delusion that's
never come there's people that are
actually waiting in l.a they're saying
let's let everybody else go so we get
all the acting and stand-up comedy roles
first of all
they just announced it probably not
going to be any [ __ ] stand-up in l.a
till about [ __ ] next june
i was doubting for you and new york
they just said something about [ __ ]
no theater until [ __ ] september
so for me a guy like me what what does a
comic do
what does a comic do now a comic has to
rearrange
his [ __ ] life okay he has to start
doing
outside shows you know for however long
they [ __ ] take you
put them up yourself you got to put your
own i don't know if they have
different systems like tom segura's
doing to do
live shows get for your friends get the
camera work and [ __ ] do a live show
and charge 10 bucks admission
but one thing about this pandemic at
first
i looked at it as a breather but now
i'm looking at it as you got to live
your life
i know people that haven't left that
[ __ ] bedroom since this happened
i know people who haven't left that
[ __ ] house since this happened
and i got to tell you something i'm a
[ __ ] scary cat [ __ ]
i left the house against my best wishes
because i knew
i didn't want to fall into that [ __ ]
trap i mean it's
very easy to wake up go in front of the
news
have them [ __ ] piss on your leg and
crawl right back into bed
trust me there were days i wanted to do
this with this [ __ ] pandemic but
i pay what would happen if i would have
gone back to bed that's the beginning of
depression
that's how you get your depression
started by getting up eating something
saying i failed today
and then going back to bed that's the
roots of depression that's the roots
well i don't know how bipolar bipolar
whatever but that's the roots
because now they have bipolar depression
jesus [ __ ] christ
what's next stuttering bipolar
depression so while you're sitting there
[ __ ] stuttering you gotta
depress you gotta tell people i'm
you know it never ends with the diseases
i'm talking about just regular
depression
where you see yourself going nowhere you
know
you don't have the energy
you don't even understand why you want
to do what you're doing
that's the worst kind of depression so
from the beginning of this [ __ ]
pandemic
i made sure to get up take a shower
if you're going to work as if you're
going to work
you should be taking a shower anyway you
filthy [ __ ] what do you do walk
around with stinky but you're not taking
a shower
and then go to pee at six o'clock and
you feel the side of your thigh and you
feel that [ __ ] nut butter on your leg
you wouldn't have that nut butter on
your leg if you wash your balls
for breakfast because when you wash your
balls for breakfast it stimulates the
ball sack
you [ __ ] cover it up with some
[ __ ] soap
and it keeps under control when you
don't take a shower and go out at six
and you come back at six o'clock pee and
rub that [ __ ]
nut butter from your leg and see what it
smells like it don't smell right
that's not [ __ ] normal that's why you
take a shower before you leave the house
especially women i don't want to see
that crinkle cut when i'm standing
behind you at the bagel store
that you just got up with that rotten
[ __ ] [ __ ] and went out
you got to watch that [ __ ] monkey the
same thing you gotta wash that [ __ ]
helmet
you gotta bathe every day twice a day i
don't give a [ __ ] about water shortage
oh well if we bathe twice a day there
won't be any water
in 2060 [ __ ] them [ __ ] them let them
worry take them back with ice cubes i
don't give a [ __ ] climate change climate
control
get up take a shower as if
you're gonna go to work okay as if
you're gonna go to work you're gonna
write in your journal
as if you're gonna go to work you're
gonna drink some [ __ ] coffee
as if you're gonna go to work you're
gonna open up the front door
look outside and say to yourself it's
[ __ ] monday
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
i don't care if your mind is 16
in your checking account i don't give a
[ __ ] if you haven't paid rent in six
months
they can't put you in debt as prison
it's still a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive
you look outside and then you figure out
what the [ __ ] you want to do
if you got a day job you do your day job
from the computer
but this is the time to start working on
that website you weren't thinking about
for a year
this is the time to start work dejean
got dick
when you ain't got dick you ain't got
nothing to lose you think i started
stand up with a testerosa and a [ __ ]
and like a butler no when you start
something
you started at bad bones just like this
[ __ ] podcast
i could have waited three weeks and came
at you with lights and cameras and a bar
and booze whatever [ __ ] that you don't
need that
what we need right now is communication
what we need right now is to help each
other
what we need right now is to look at
each other not a text to check in
this is a [ __ ] personal check-in from
your uncle joey letting you know
i'm still slinging dick and giving out
bubble gum and it's because of you guys
so i intend you to be doing the same for
me
you like a new setup huh look at that i
got bruce lee
i got sid the squid monk grief over here
[ __ ] tremendous i'm gonna have julia
serving there but it's not finished yet
but i'm gonna have all my idols i got
palisades amusement park
where i grew up i got my man charles
bronson look at him like a bad
[ __ ] that he is
and i got me and rogan and [ __ ] vegas
doing our thing
and look at this new picture this new
picture is just slow
chasing lee as he's driving across
country and going oh my god i can't
believe it
well no this picture is acdc
june 30th 1979 you ready for this
four days maybe five days before i saw
him august 4th
1979 with ted at madison square garden
ask me joey do i give a [ __ ] i'm just
telling you what i'm saying because i'm
a nice [ __ ]
guy that's it what else do you want from
me man
it's going to be a [ __ ] great week
the patreon
moves up today 3 5
10 and 15 beans we got
nice hooded sweatshirts for you for the
fifteen dollar
we got nice uh long sleeve tees for you
and we're gonna keep doing what we're
doing giving you nothing but content
like i told you it's gonna be a cold
[ __ ] winter and you know what
i'm gonna need you as much as you're
gonna need me
so we're gonna work [ __ ] together i'm
gonna create this [ __ ] basement into
a content
[ __ ] studio of love you understand me
i hope you enjoyed the album of the week
on patreon i'm trying my best this week
we're covering another
iconic album one of my all-time
favorites uh
i put it on the other day and i got to
tell you something i had like a [ __ ]
tear in my eye
because it is true music is a part of
your childhood
it just taps into a special time
and it's not all the time it's not all
the time
it's sometimes you just catch that
[ __ ] magic
you put on an album and you're like [ __ ]
i still remember being on the corner
with one-eyed louie and
you know this guy and it was cold and we
stepped on dog [ __ ]
this is great guys this is great that
you know what what
we're doing this with a [ __ ] iphone
an amazon microphone on amazon we should
just call this the amazon podcast
because this is brought to you with low
[ __ ] it's not even low quality i mean
this the itunes
the i uh phone camera is [ __ ]
tremendous
you're hearing me i'm looking good
and uh everything's great guys i just
want to check in with you and let you
know that you're doing fine
you're not [ __ ] dead listen we lost
eddie van halen last week
roger holloway and my man whitey fought
this has been going around it has
nothing to do with you
do not let it affect who the [ __ ] you
are
and what your goals are you understand
me it's not letting me effective my
goals are
i'm a little scared the numbers might
come back they might not
what do i look like doctor [ __ ]
vouching to you i don't give a [ __ ] all
you can do is take care of you
wear your mask wash your hands wash your
hands before you touch your dick
you don't want somebody sucking your
dick and getting covered because they
suck your dick and they gotta trace
it back to your dick can you imagine
that people knocking on your door
hey charlie you got covered on your dick
you need that problem in your life
wash your hands before you let the poor
girl lick your [ __ ] nut sack and
ladies youtube
don't finger bang yourself with your
filthy [ __ ] fingers
after [ __ ] nancy wu gave you a
manicure
and then you want me to go down there
and lick your [ __ ] monkey
and next thing you know i got nancy
who's fingers in my mouth
and i'm coughing and i'm spreading
[ __ ] [ __ ] relax
you got to wash your hands before you
touch your private parts
same thing for your [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] go to wipe your ass the toilet
paper slips
and you get that thing in your [ __ ]
and then now what now you want to walk
around
and give people directions by pointing
knock it the [ __ ] off
wash your [ __ ] hands you filthy
[ __ ]
as of right now all i got is uncle
vinnie's for the whole month
of [ __ ] uh october
again i got this wednesday next
wednesday
and wednesday the 28th then we have an
election month hopefully this movie
comes through
this is not going to affect our podcast
this is not going to affect anything
in the middle of all this pandemic and
stuff i know you're having
[ __ ] those self doubts [ __ ]
[ __ ] those self doubts you got to grab
your balls and tell yourself you're
going to push yourself through this
you got to keep yourself in control
especially if you have a family
because [ __ ] runs downhill if you walk
around
looking like johnny mort your family's
gonna feel like johnny moth
you gotta walk around like he just hit
the [ __ ] lottery like the guy knocked
behind your door with that big [ __ ]
check
so your family doesn't feel what you're
going through
it's in the air but it doesn't have to
affect you and your family
you could treat this [ __ ] differently
i know i have but i'm not gonna lie to
you when i first got here
i was walking around scared shitless
fear
is not in your [ __ ] vocabulary when
you see the shirts that come out for
this stuff which i posted
on patreon you'll see all the [ __ ] you
have to conquer in the circle
that was the mind of joey diaz whether
it was the drugs the kidnappings
and it was only one kidnapping singular
i'm sorry i put that thing up the other
day but it's always nice to [ __ ]
kidnap a [ __ ]
drug dealer who would kidnap a governor
who the [ __ ]
what what would you do with that
governor
what would you do what are you going to
hold the [ __ ] ransom who's going to
give you any [ __ ] money who's going
to give you dick for a [ __ ] governor
who wants a governor in their [ __ ]
basement do you know what kind of what's
going to come at you
fbi's zingers they're going to [ __ ]
destroy you
so for uh for you to think that you're
going to that's a bad idea listen
it was a bad idea when i kidnapped bella
it's a bad idea to kidnap anybody just
shoot him in the lake take what they got
and go home
what are you gonna take from the [ __ ]
governor nothing i mean she's cute what
are you gonna do you're gonna [ __ ] are
you filthy [ __ ]
give yourself a break who the [ __ ]
kidnapped some [ __ ] governor this is
what i'm talking about here
we're going to [ __ ] people but we got
uncle joey's joint to keep us hocus
pocused
it's at the end of his rope i got a
little recharge i don't even know what
this is popping up here
whatever the [ __ ] this is what is this
[ __ ] here
before your ears maybe you put something
in your [ __ ] ears what the [ __ ] knows
hey this [ __ ] goes fast you know what
i'm saying you know with me
nothing [ __ ] lasts i just want you to
come
you had a [ __ ] monday morning talk to
you about what's going on in my life
and just remember one thing i got a
second chance
i got a second chance of being a father
i got a second chance of being a husband
i got a second chance of being a human
being
i got a second chance of [ __ ] just
doing everything over
you know from prison the whole thing if
i could do it
could you imagine what the [ __ ] you
could do
i got a [ __ ] ged can you imagine what
you could do with a family and support
and the love that you have around you
stop looking
outside for [ __ ] what you're looking for
is right within it's within your family
it's within yourself you just got to
stop [ __ ] around
and smoking dope and telling me uncle
joey i i i got pineapple express who
gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] tell me that you
[ __ ] got 100 on your [ __ ] paper
that makes my dick get
happier that's what makes uncle joey
happy
that you young [ __ ] are pushing
it through here enough with the [ __ ]
there's nothing going on
club mtv is gone you can't jump up and
down right now
there's nowhere to go you're living off
virtual classes
now is your time to put your hustle
together if you want a graphic design if
you want to draw
this is the time because you know what
you ain't got nothing to lose
and when you ain't got nothing to lose
that's when you're at your finest
[ __ ] moment
like me what are you gonna take from me
i come on here say whatever the [ __ ] i
want what are you gonna do
throw me into jail not anymore guys it's
my [ __ ] world
which means it's your [ __ ] world i'm
you with you
you're with me and these punk ass
[ __ ] want to be with us
i'll see you guys wednesday morning tip
top [ __ ] magoo ready to [ __ ] go
you understand me i love you guys have a
great [ __ ] day
have a great week remember today the
patreon keys go up to three dollars
if you're a dollar guy you get
grandfathered i'm not mad at you
you still got the bunch of stuff if you
want the dear abby it goes up to five
i get a thousand emails a day guys we
gotta trim those down
and i also i'm adding the music show
and i'm also adding a live [ __ ]
little get-together for you
you just don't know when it's gonna
happen it's gonna just pop up because
that's how i fly
i don't know when the girls are gonna
leave so i don't know when i can
smoke a joint with you guys so they'll
be around also on patreon
but beside that for you podcast
[ __ ]
i love you we're working on uncle joey's
joints t-shirts
we're working on a lot of things but
it's one thing at a time all right
this week we added some light we had a
little curtain
we're gonna put this one together right
before your [ __ ] eyes
every week we're gonna get stronger and
stronger
and we're not gonna utilize the bar
except for sports companion shows how's
that one for you we'll have a good time
we'll do a little drinking
we'll sell some tickets and that's how
we'll do the [ __ ] bar
that's how we'll do the bar okay beside
that
you got me uncle joey's joint is here
number [ __ ] three we're doing what
we're doing to the best of our abilities
just to show you you don't need the
[ __ ]
all this [ __ ] to [ __ ] get your word
out if you want to get your word out
it's right in front of you
i love you [ __ ] thank you for
listening to uncle joey's uh
joint and don't forget to support our
sponsors
whether it's [ __ ] cbd lion whether
it's draftkings
or whether it's lucy co do not forget to
support them
thank you very much have a great week
i'll see you [ __ ] wednesday
all right i want to thank you for
listening to uncle joey's joint today
it's a beautiful [ __ ] monday but
first before we leave listen
uncle joy's joint is brought for you
from the heart of new jersey
[ __ ] draftkings you understand me
week five of football is in the books
now it's time to review the tape and get
ready for
week six listen to me i don't know what
the [ __ ] to tell you football is [ __ ]
tremendous this year
this is your time to make some money
everybody's waiting for [ __ ] ppe
money and whatever [ __ ] that [ __ ]
draftkings is back
and you can't miss this offer if you
haven't tried it yet this is the time to
jump on board okay
they're giving all new users the chance
to receive a sign up bonus of up to a
thousand dollars
for you [ __ ] momos waiting for
unemployment there it is
you put in a grand they give you a grand
who else is giving your dick these days
nobody on top of that they got great
odds boost
every sunday you make money with your
feet up like a [ __ ] doctor
all you need is a [ __ ] little half
[ __ ] asian [ __ ] to come over and
lick your nuts
best part is draftkings is based right
here in the us
it's safe secure reliable deposit and
withdraw money
at your convenience it's your [ __ ]
getters what's the big [ __ ] deal i
want my bucket money
you like maury's wings i want my money
download the top-rated draftking sports
book app now
and use code church to get a thousand
dollars did you hear me
you get a [ __ ] grand when you get the
draftking sports app and use code church
only at draftkingsportsbook and here's
the best part that the lawyers make you
[ __ ] say all right
you got to be over 21 older new jersey
indiana and pennsylvania only
just you three times [ __ ] for
starters you people know how to [ __ ]
gamble
deposit bonus requires 25 times played
through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help for you call 1-800 gambler
or if you're in indiana call 1-800-9
with it and tell him uncle joey sent you
but if not
download the draftking sports app and
use code church
and let's get this [ __ ] party started
and the story
the church is often brought to you by
cbd
lion listen when it comes to cbd i'm
down with these guys i try them all
and this stuff works anxiety
pain whatever the [ __ ] you got you go on
the cbdline.com website
they'll tell you exactly what products
you need and how they're going to work
with cbn cbd blah blah blah
you know me i'm no [ __ ] doctor i'm
just telling you
what's the best thing out there for what
you're going through all right
so do me a favor go to cbdline.com
look at the products they have from the
tinctures
to the gummies to the bath balls to the
roll-on
to the tape i mean cbd lion got it all
go to cbdlion.com right now and pressing
joey
and get 10 off the living right to your
[ __ ] crib
who's better than them no liquor store
no tire shop cbd
none of that [ __ ] use your [ __ ] head
all right cbdlion.com
joey also you ready for this
lucy nicotine gun why are you [ __ ]
smoking you're smoking 19 packs now
during this [ __ ] pandemic you know
how it is to quit it's [ __ ] hard
so when you're craving the smoke you
just need a little something to satisfy
the habit you step outside you take a
moment
you take a breath of fresh air you say
hell mary and you pop one of these in
your
mouth you're as good as new jack i think
a craving
only lasts like 40 seconds or some [ __ ]
so you just got to get your mind off it
it's 20 20. things may be rough but you
don't need to smoke anymore
it's really gonna [ __ ] you up so get
lucy
today so you're prepared so when you get
the itch
lucy gum actually tastes good it comes
in three flavors i mean i switched
governments
went to green cinnamon and pomegranate
is delicious
they've also got a cherry ice flavored
lozenge that'll make your [ __ ] wig
light on fire okay all right
like i said pomegranate with me is my
favorite
buy a pack of lucy keep it on you when
you're craving slack strikes
and when you least expect it lucy is
discreet and you can take it
with you anywhere this is the real deal
a subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door
each month it's so simple you don't even
have to leave the house because
lucy has delivery [ __ ] down
most lucy's do anyway uncle joey's joint
listeners
go to lucy.com ceo and use promo coach
promo code joey to get 20 off all
products including gum
and lozenges that's lucy dot co
and use promo code joey at checkout
also i got to give you this disclaimer
warning
the product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical
go to lucy.com and be sure to use
promo coach joey see you [ __ ]
wednesday morning
i love you guys thank you for supporting
uncle joey's joint
it's over [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you